i need your help in understanding what's
going on with the washington football
team one of the rivals of your
dallas cowboys they wish they had a guy
like number 12 for the cowboys the
jersey hanging over your shoulder
they don't so it's dwayne haskins down
kyle
allen up alex smith elevated to number
two
haskins all the way to number three
shireen let's hear from coach ron rivera
about why he's made this decision
to go with kyle allen i just felt
you know based on the things that have
gone on with dwayne
based on his development and where he is
um
it's we're better off putting the ball
in the hands of guys that know our
system
a guy that's been in our system for
three years uh backed up by a guy that's
been in the system before and
and is a little bit more accomplished
quarterback this is not an indictment on
on dwayne as much as indictment on the
situation circumstances that we are in
you know he did not have the benefit of
otas and minicamp he didn't have the
benefit of four preseason games to work
through things
and because of that he's behind
in his development in the system and
again it's it's an unfortunate situation
so look here's the bottom line iran
river was very diplomatic about it but
the reality is dwayne haskins isn't
getting
getting it done and they've got other
options
that know the system better shireen and
they're going to go with those guys
instead of giving dwayne haskins the
opportunity to learn the system on the
fly it is an indictment of dwayne
haskins it is a benching of dwayne
haskins and it calls into question the
future
of the guy who was the 15th overall pick
in the 2019 draft
yeah no question about it and you know i
saw kyle allen play enough in college at
texas a m
and there's a reason he transferred to
university of houston and there's a
reason that he got benched as a starter
at the university of houston
there's a reason he didn't finish as a
starter at carolina i mean
this is a backup quarterback i think he
can be a really good backup quarterback
but he's not a starting quarterback you
drafted dwayne haskins 15th overall last
year to be your franchise quarterback
and now there are serious questions
about whether he
is that guy the good news for washington
and for
everyone i think we all applaud this is
alex smith will dress for a game
for the first time in 693 days that's
when he was carted off the field
that's the really great news out of all
this but washington has a big problem
mike
because they look like they're headed
toward having one of the worst records
in the nfl i know it's
early but if they do do you do what the
cardinals
did do you bail on dwayne haskins and go
get the guy you think
is better in the draft i think you do
and i think that decision's already been
made otherwise haskins wouldn't have
been benched by the way
ron rivera was far more diplomatic about
dwayne haskins than you were about kyle
allen
you delivered it with a straight face
you you you weren't
mean about it but you've made it clear
that kyle allen is a backup for a reason
and frankly i don't expect him
to be the starter for very long i think
it's just a matter of time
before the ending to the alex smith
disney movie happens
and he's back on the field but here's
the thing here's the thing
this isn't your normal one and three
team that's being left in the dust
this is a one and three team that is a
half game out of first place in its
division
so it's not time to fold the tents on
the season just yet
this is about trying to will their way
into contention
with someone who they think gives them a
better chance to win shireen and they
think kyle allen for now gives them a
better chance
and before too long i think they're
going to think alex smith gives him
gives them a better chance to win
well there's a reason that they trade it
for kyle it's because they had him scott
turner the offensive coordinator who is
the son of north turner
had him in carolina he does know the
system he
played in the system he is better in the
system right now than dwayne haskins
there's no question about that i mean
he's just done it for far
longer with no offs no real off season
program for dwayne haskins to learn the
system
i get that but you know now to me
is the time that you figure out if
haskins is your quarterback of the
future you take your lumps
i realize they're a half game out
whoever wins the east we don't expect
them to go far on the postseason anyway
and we
we know that's i understand you try to
win your division you want to win games
all that
this is the first year that ron rivera's
been in this organization
he's had a lot of problems he has a long
way to go to turn this thing around to
me you play haskins and figure out if
you need to go get that
quarterback in the early in the draft
next year
and alex smith knows the system not
because he's played for scott turner he
played for north turner that's
that's how long alex smith has been
around but he knows the system and i
think it's going to be him before too
long
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports